[Music]
singing along with Taylor Swift in
cinematic form is a new horror series
from the master in the genre the
animated return of some guy named Morty
and another named Rick a horror comedy
series that will give you Goosebumps and
a Revival series that's worth a cheers
it's all coming up on this week's what
to watch do a show with like all the
albums in it and I was like yeah it's
it's it's going to be called The Arrow
tour see you
there hitting theaters and creating
plenty of buzz in the process is Taylor
Swift the aist tour this film documents
Taylor's aist tour the still ongoing
World Tour that perhaps you've heard
about considering the economic impact
it's having from City to City this one
was filmed over three nights at La Sofi
stadium and all that above is the first
reason to join in on the ticket buying
fun what do we mean by Fun well the
ticket demand has been record-
breakingly high with 37 million in
pre-sales on its first day and already
over a 100 million in global pre-sales
and let's be honest not everybody got to
see her in person at one of the live
shows so this one is the next best thing
you don't want to miss out on something
like that right that's reason number two
the third is that she put Travis Kelce
on the map but also by teaming directly
with the theaters and bypassing the
studios to release the movie Taylor has
once again done things her way and gosh
darn it it was a great idea although the
sudden announcement of a release date
caused some studios to scramble and move
other movie releases out of the way
lol it's
time
it's
time arriving on Netflix is the gothic
horror miniseries The Fall of the House
of Usher this is Loosely based on the
short story of the same name and other
works by Edgar alen Poe so this reason
is for all you poads out there I see you
it follows the story of a pharmaceutical
Empire and The Heirs to the dynasty Who
start dying reason too is that this show
comes from horror veteran Mike Flanigan
who created The Haunting Anthology
series for Netflix and who is the Mind
behind horror flick like Ouija origin of
evil and Dr sleep he just gets it and
hey don't take my word for it the Fall
of the House of Usher is already
certified fresh at 95% on the Tomato
Meter with about 40 reviews and Counting
and the critics love seeing pose stories
told through Flanigan's deliciously dark
lens hey look Morty I'm a leg a leg
Morty any progress I found the version
of me that killed my wife you just
missed
it return into the Airways for a seventh
season is the adult animated series Rick
and Morty and the first reason to tune
into this one is actually six reasons
all rolled up into one meaning the first
six seasons are all fresh on the Tomato
Meter with four of them certified fresh
that's a good reason for any first ERS a
second reason to watch is more for R and
M fans because this reason hints at the
return of some fan favorite characters
including Mr Poopy butthole yes I just
said that out loud if you know you know
and with the exit of co-creator Justin
royland this season will will feature a
bunch of new what the Adult Swim bigwigs
are calling sound alike voices to
replace the ones he voiced and if plain
old curiosity can't be its own reason to
watch then what is life I did hear the
horrible story about the boy who used to
live there you know I hear it's
[Music]
haunted creeping up on Disney plus and
Hulu this week is Goosebumps the series
this horror comedy is of course based on
the popular book series of the same name
by RL Stein so this reason is All For
You Stein heads out there is that a
thing the series features Justin Long
leading a young cast of five teenagers
who ACD dentally release Supernatural
forces and have to figure out how to
recapture them and we know Slappy the
Dummy is indeed set to appear so that's
got to be its own reason right thirdly
the show which is set at an early 100%
on the Tomato Meter was developed by Rob
Letterman who directed the 2015
Goosebumps film and Nicholas Stoler
known for directing comedies like
Forgetting Sarah Marshall and neighbors
not a bad ComEd for this horror comedy
series sitting here with a cold brew in
my hand I feel Amalgamated with the Hoy
pooy you are the classic Everyman
clocking in for another run in the
sitcom world is Frasier this is indeed a
Revival of the popular 90s series of the
same name and the same star Kelsey
gramar as Dr Frasier Crane a character
that first originated on the hit 80s
show Cheers and that whole mess of
nostalgia is reason number one to find
this one on Paramount plus another
reason is that this has been described
by grammar as a third act in Fraser's
life that comes with a new/old location
Boston the location of Cheers but
different from the Seattle setting in
the 9s show with that will come all new
supporting characters as well but fear
not Frasier heads a couple of familiar
faces are confirmed to be making an
appearance in this new version BB
newworth as Frasier's ex-wife Lilith and
Perry Gilpin as Fraser's old coworker
Raz that can be reason number three but
don't forget the original series 1 37
Emmy Awards including outstanding comedy
series five straight years it's no
wonder everybody knows his
name there you go five picks that will
make you forget that you never got
tickets to Taylor Swift be sure to let
us and your fellow viewers know in the
comments what you did check out whether
it was on this list or not remember to
check out Ron tomatoes.com for the
latest updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large that's all
for today fresh family until next week
stay
fresh